Let's get started. So,
first of all, I have to apologize to the
students in my class because we're still
not done grading the midterm.
Uh we're hoping to be done with it
today. I had hoped to be done with it uh
before class today, and then uh I wanted
to talk a little bit about it, but um
we we're we're still not we're still not
done, and it's my fault. Uh there's one
question though
that's on the midterm that I wanted to
talk about right now uh because it's a
question that that some people struggled
with, and um
uh even though not all of the midterm uh
the midterm we're even though we're not
done grading it yet, and not everybody
has their midterm back yet, uh I still
thought it would be a good idea to talk
about this one uh
just because I I feel like this is a a
very fundamental thing where if if if
you don't understand this one thing, uh
then it's going to hinder your
understanding of other things in the
course. So, so let's talk about it.
Um so, the question
uh on the midterm was um
essentially uh
what do you use a physical clock for in
distributed systems, and what what
shouldn't you use a physical clock for
in distributed systems? So, um
so, physical clocks
what are
and aren't
they good for
in distributed systems?
So, we talked about two kinds of
physical clocks. Uh if you recall, we
talked about uh time-of-day clocks, and
we talked about monotonic clocks. Those
are both physical clocks. So,
time-of-day and monotonic clocks
both fall into the category of physical
clocks.
As opposed to logical clocks.
And so,
we made a little sort of uh
uh grid, or we could make a grid, of
what these two different kinds of clocks
are good for.
So,
if we say time of day
and monotonic
here,
and then
say
uh marking points in time
here,
and
durations
or intervals of time.
So, let's talk about time of day clocks
first.
Uh time of day clocks
are bad for marking durations or
intervals of time. They're bad for
marking durations or intervals of time
because they can jump around.
So, if you want to measure 5 seconds and
you're doing that by measuring the
current time of day time
and then measuring the current time of
day time later and and seeing that 5
seconds went by, uh
you can't it it it you can't accurately
measure that 5 seconds went by by
measuring by subtracting one time from
the other uh because that time of day
time could change due to things like
leap seconds. Um so, that's no good.
As far as marking points in time, um
time of day times or let me let me put a
sad face here, actually.
Um so, time of day times might be
okay-ish for marking points in time, but
they're really not good for marking
points of time in distributed systems
because processes don't share a time of
day clock.
So, at best
this is like a neutral face here.
Monotonic clocks are great for measuring
durations or intervals because they only
go forward.
But mono- monotonic clocks are no good
for marking points in time because the
value of a monotonic clock isn't
comparable between machines. Recall that
a monotonic clock is something like a
counter that counts up the milliseconds
uh since your machine started. Uh
according to the POSIX standard, I was
looking at this yesterday, uh the POSIX
standard says that uh
the the that a monotonic clock uh counts
forward from  some unspecified
point in the past.  Uh so,
whatever it is, it's not going to be
comparable to what your neighbor's
machine's monotonic clock says. Um so,
monotonic clocks are no good for marking
points in time because whatever point in
time you have your on your monotonic
clock is going to be meaningless to
everyone else.
So, there's our picture. Um
so,
these are the two kinds of physical
clocks, time of day and monotonic. We
got sad faces here. We got a neutral
face here. The only happy face we have
is right here. So, this is what I was
expecting you to say, and in particular,
what do we use monotonic clocks for in
distributed systems? Timeouts. We use
them for implementing timeouts.
So,
timeouts are essential in distributed
systems as we've been talking about. If
you need to do failure detection uh in
Paxos, if a if a proposer needs to
decide, "Oh, I haven't heard back from
enough acceptors yet, so maybe I should
send out a new higher proposal number."
Uh and you're going to need to use
timeouts on the assignment that you're
implementing now uh in order to um in
order to to to detect when a
when a replica is down. So,
timeouts, that's what you that's what
you should use physical clocks for. And
it's a good idea to use monotonic clocks
for them because otherwise, you might
run into issues with, uh, with
measuring, uh,
a length of time that you didn't intend
to measure.
So, um, so that's that's what physical
clocks are good for. In terms of what
physical clocks aren't good for,
really the thing that I was looking for
here was physical clocks are unsuitable
for measuring order of events.
If you had something about how physical
clocks are are not suitable for
measuring order of the of events, that's
that's like if you take one thing away
from this class, if you remember one
thing, remember that it's a bad idea to
use physical clocks for measuring order
of events.
Why? Well,
if you look at what So, how would you
measure order of events? Well, you would
do it by trying to mark points in time
and then comparing them, right? Uh, but
then, when you look at those marked
points in time and you try to compare
them, you shouldn't use time of day
clocks for it because, uh,
what one clock thinks or what one
process thinks a partic- is a particular
time might be different from, uh, from
what another process thinks. And then,
monotonic clocks aren't comparable at
all between processes. So, those those
are going to be meaningless for
comparisons.
Uh, so physical clocks are no good for
uh, for for for order of events, uh,
because in order to determine order of
events, you have to mark points in time,
and physical clocks aren't good for that
in distributed systems. Now, some people
answered this question when I asked, um,
"What are physical clocks good for in
distributed systems?" Some of you said
something like, "Well, they're good if
you only have one machine." Okay, but
that wouldn't be a distributed system.
So, that wasn't really what I was going
for there.
Um, I gave a lot of partial credit on
this one. So, I gave partial credit if
you said something like uh
if if first of all, if you if you if you
made this point about how uh physical
clocks aren't suitable for determining
order of events, then I automatically
gave you half the credit there uh even
if everything else you said was garbage
on this question because that that one
point is is the one thing that I most
want people to take away from this
class.
Um, but yeah, I was I was really looking
for people to mention timeouts. And
then, if you happen to mention or if you
happen to explain why uh
time of day clocks aren't great for
timeouts, uh then I would give some
credit for that as well. Um, but yeah,
that's that's what I was going for on
this question. Um, and I I think a lot
of people uh
um missed this. Maybe maybe it was just
because uh it it it was so long ago
because we covered this at the very
beginning of the class.
Uh, but come talk to me if you have any
questions about about what I just said.
Um,
I don't want to talk about the exam
anymore today cuz we have a lot of other
stuff to talk about. And as I mentioned,
we're still not done grading it. Sorry.
Um, but let's move on and talk about the
actual content for today. Um, but
hopefully we'll have the the the the
rest of the exams uh finished grading
soon. And then, please come talk to any
of us. Um, I So, unfortunately, we don't
have time to give detailed feedback on
every question on every exam. I tried to
give detailed feedback on a couple of
them. Uh,
some other people did, too. But, if we
did give detailed feedback on every
question, which it's an exam of mostly
essay questions, um
then it it would have been uh then then
you'd be waiting a lot longer to get
your exam back if that were the case.
So, um unfortunately, we just don't have
the bandwidth and of course the size.
Uh, but you should come talk to us if
you have questions about uh
a particular problem on the exam.
All right. So,
let's go back to talking about Paxos.
So, um
uh in our first lecture on Paxos, uh we
looked at a at a sort of easy, happy run
of Paxos. Um, and then last time we
started to talk about some um, some
cases where more interesting things had
could happen. And that sort of led us
into talking about this situation, uh,
where you could have multiple proposers.
And uh, we began to anticipate in the
questions that we that people were
asking last time, uh, how that could
could lead to problems. Um, so if you
recall, we talked about the three
properties that that consensus
algorithms try to satisfy. Um, somebody
want to remind me what those three
properties are that that consensus
algorithms try to satisfy?
Okay, integrity. Um,
also known as validity.
Termination and agreement.
Uh, so what does validity or integrity
say? It says the agreed upon value has
to be one of the proposed values.
Um,
agreement says that the values actually
agree.
And termination says that the algorithm
terminates. Every line coming out of the
consensus box
will have a value on it.
So, which of these properties did we say
Paxos compromises on? Because every
consensus algorithm has to compromise on
one of them, at least. So, which one
does Paxos not satisfy?
Termination. Yeah. So, a run of Paxos
might not terminate.
So, now that we've talked about the full
Paxos algorithm,
you might start to have a sense about
what kind of a situation would lead to
Paxos not terminate.
And in a nutshell, it's a situation
where you have different proposers
contending with each other forever.
Um so, for example, um here's something
that could happen.
So, we have, let's say,
um two proposers,
P1 and P2, and three acceptors,
like before.
And we'll say that that things start out
the same as as they did before,
with P1 going first.
So, P1 will do its thing. Um it'll send
its prepare message
to a majority of acceptors.
It'll hear back with promises.
So, these are both promise five.
Um and let's say that over here, P2
sends, uh uh let's say that it sends
prepare six.
Let's say that it sends it to A2 and A3.
So, A3 is going to respond with promise
six.
And so is A2. So, A2 promised five back
here, but all that means is it's
promising to ignore requests that have a
proposal number lower than five. So,
there's nothing stopping it from also
promising six over here.
So, here's its promise six. This uh
uh caption corresponds to both of these
arrows here.
So, then
P1 gets around to sending its accept.
So, it's going to send an accept message
with the proposal number and then
whatever value it is that it's trying to
propose.
And that message is going to get here
um and it's going to be ignored on
acceptor two, right? Because acceptor
two has promised six, which means
acceptor two has promised to ignore all
requests that have a a proposal number
lower than six.
Now, A1 didn't promise six, so A1
will accept.
But, P1 will be sitting there waiting to
get accepted messages back from a
majority of acceptors and it won't ever
get them, so
it'll time out.
It'll try again.
So, maybe now it sends a prepare seven.
And both of the acceptors respond
with a promise.
Okay.
Over here on P2, it got its promise from
the majority of acceptors here. So now
it wants to It It wants to send its
accept message. So it sends its accept
message here
of six
and whatever value it is that it's it
wants to
propose.
So it sends that out.
A3 will accept.
But if that accept message hits over
here on A2,
after A2 has already promised seven,
then this will be ignored.
So here's our ignored messages.
And now
P2 will time out here waiting to hear
from a majority of acceptors.
And this could go on forever. So in this
case, neither P1 nor P2 is able to get a
majority of acceptors to respond to
their accept messages.
Uh um somebody asked, "Wasn't A2
supposed to send an accepted uh message
to P1 uh here?" Well, it can't here
because it promised six already. So a
promise means, "I promise to ignore all
messages that have a proposal number
less than six."
So it has to ignore this message coming
in here because that message has a
proposal number of only five.
So, consensus is never reached here
because there's no point where a
majority of acceptors send accept
accepted messages for a particular value
in a proposal number.
I happen to do this here with with
three, um but A3 actually wouldn't even
have to be involved in order for there
to be non-termination. You could just
have a run where P1 and P2 are both just
communicating with A1 and A2 and the
messages still land in just the wrong
order so that all the accept messages
get ignored.
So, here's a question for you.
All of this non-termination badness
seems to come up as a result of having
multiple proposers.
Okay, so why not just have one proposer?
Why do we have to have two proposers?
Well, okay, so one reason is fault
tolerance, right? What if the proposer
fails? Uh you don't want the only
proposer to die.
Um but I think there's even another
reason. Um
so let's just say for the sake of
argument that we aren't worried about
data loss when the one proposer dies
because we'll say that it somehow uh
writes everything that it does to stable
storage. So, if it dies, and it's the
only proposer, then the only issue then
is picking a node to take over for it.
Uh well, that's a leader election
problem. And leader election requires
consensus.
And so,
if you wanted to require there to be
exactly one proposer, and you tried to
use Paxos to try to figure out who that
proposer should be, Paxos might not
terminate.
So,
you can't require that there's only one
proposer, because then your consensus
algorithm would depend on a consensus
algorithm. Uh this is actually what some
consensus algorithms do. They have a
phase where they elect a leader.
And then that leader election process
requires consensus. And then, once
they've elected a leader, that leader
proposes values.
And then that is more straightforward,
because they don't have to reason about
this case where they have multiple
proposers. Um but leader election itself
could be non-terminating. And so, they
don't get around the non-termination
problem.
So, last time I mentioned that
it might make sense for some consensus
protocols. Actually, don't remember if I
really talked about this, but but but um
but let's talk about it. So,
if if consensus protocols have to pick
two out of these three properties of of
termination, agreement, and validity.
Um and we've been choosing agreement and
validity, and saying, "Okay,
termination's out the window." Um
but would it ever make sense to to to
pick a different combination? Um
So, what about what about if you throw
agreement out the window? So, agreement,
recall, is the property that the um of
the of the three lines coming out of the
consensus box, um they all actually have
to have the same value on them. So,
would it ever make sense to to sacrifice
that? Well, before I said no, right?
Because um
be- because that's the whole problem
that we're trying to solve. Um but it
might actually make sense for some
consensus protocols to choose
termination and validity and compromise
on agreement. Um and leader election
could actually be a case of that. So,
maybe you're okay with actually having
multiple leaders chosen by a leader
election protocol as long as it
terminates.
Um so, a thing you could actually do is
use a leader election protocol that
doesn't satisfy agreement, but does
satisfy termination and validity
and use it to pick who should be the
proposer for a run of Paxos. If it
happens to pick multiple nodes
sometimes, then that would be okay
because Paxos still works when there are
multiple proposers. Um and if it's still
If it still picks a single node most of
the time, then great.
Um so, this is a good lead-in actually
to the next thing that I want to talk
about, um which is which is called
multi-Paxos.
So, we have been talking about using
Paxos to decide on a single value.
That's what Paxos does. It decides on
one value.
So,
if you want to decide on a sequence of
values, you have to run Paxos again.
Uh well, it turns out that deciding on a
sequence of values is a really common
thing to want to do. Um so, for example,
uh when I put uh all those problems on
the uh down that all boiled down to
consensus, one of those problems, if you
recall, was the problem of totally
ordered broadcast. Um so, totally
ordered broadcast uh
is the problem of making sure that a
bunch of processes all deliver the same
messages in the same order.
Um so, that's essentially the problem of
getting consensus on what message should
be first, then getting consensus on what
message should be second, and then
getting consensus on what message should
be third,
and so on.
So,
totally ordered broadcast
um
boils down to
repeated
consensus
on single values.
Does anybody see any problem with that?
Why might that not be great?
Seems very repetitive and non-efficient.
Yeah, it could be really slow, right?
Cuz even in the in the best case, Paxos
takes a lot of messages, right? Remember
Remember what the best case looks like
for Paxos.
Um in the best case,
you've got a proposer and some
acceptors,
and you've got
a prepare,
and a promise,
and an accept,
and an accepted.
All just to decide on one value. So,
that's the best case where no process
crashes, no proposers are competing with
each other, um and you have the smallest
majority in every case, it still takes
two round trips with the acceptors.
So, that's slow.
Is there anything that could be done to
make it faster so that if we have to get
consensus on many values,
we don't have to do the two round trips
to the acceptors every time?
Well, it turns out that
once you've done a full run of the
protocol like this, this is a full run
of Paxos,
with both this phase up here, this is
the prepare promise phase,
and then this phase down here, this is
the accept accepted phase,
once you've done that, now you have a
majority of acceptors on board with you,
and you can just keep keep on doing
accept and accepted phases with that
single proposer,
as long as the proposer doesn't crash.
So, you can keep on doing accept
messages
with the same proposal number, actually.
And if you want the accept messages to
be distinctively numbered, um you can
throw in another sequence number um that
would get incremented. So, it might look
like this.
Let's just talk to A1 and A2 for now.
So, let's say um proposer one sends
prepare N
and gets back promise N.
So now
they have to do the second phase.
And let's stick actually another
sequence number in there. So N val one.
And now
they can do
another
accept accepted phase.
So this is all an initial full run
of Paxos.
And then this is just the second phase
again.
And then they can keep doing that second
phase.
This is what's known as multi-Paxos.
It turns out that this is safe to do.
So if some other process
comes along
some other proposer comes along and
decides that they ought to be in charge
and they start sending proposals that
are numbered higher than N cuz we're
still using N here.
And they do And they manage to get a
quorum of acceptors, then if that
happens, then one of my accept messages
will be ignored,
and I'll time out, and I'll have to
start over again with a prepare message
and a new proposal number, and I'll
It'll gracefully degrade to just being
regular Paxos instead of Multi-Paxos.
Um but we expect that to happen rarely.
So,
it turns out that this uh this problem
of having to decide on a sequence of
values is is pretty common. I mentioned
that this is what totally ordered
broadcast uh has to do.
Um and so, one way to think about this
is that um the sequence of values that
we're deciding on
um
is like a
a log of events on each process.
So, if you can think of each process as
having a bunch of slots,
um
in which events should go.
And the consensus problem is then for
everybody to agree on what goes in slot
one, for everybody to agree on what goes
in slot two, for everybody to go uh to
agree on what goes in slot three, and so
on. Um so, this is a case where um where
you would want to have consensus. So, if
you have several events, say ABC,
and so on,
um you would want everybody to agree.
And maybe event A arrived at this
process first, but event B arrived at
this process first.
So, then uh
a round of consensus could happen, where
these different processes are proposing
the events that they think should go in
slot one.
Um so the events don't actually take
effect on these processes until it's
been agreed what should actually go in
the first slot. So they might run
consensus um and maybe B wins. Um but
that's okay.
Um they all agree that B goes first um
and then B's out of the list. So then
another round of consensus happens and
maybe A gets agreed upon that time.
And then C gets agreed upon that time.
So it turns out that many production
implementations of Paxos actually turn
out to be multi-Paxos because one of the
most common uses of consensus is to have
this sort of agreement on a sequence of
values.
Okay.
So
I've been saying over and over that
consensus algorithms can't provide all
three of agreement and validity and
termination.
But also that can't really be the whole
story because
right cuz here's a consensus protocol.
Have one acceptor.
Proposers propose values to the
acceptor. The acceptor picks one and
broadcasts it to everybody.
Done. It meets all the criteria.
Why can't we just do that?
Yeah, the acceptor might crash, right?
We want to be able to withstand some
degree of processes crashing.
So, the actual impossibility result, the
FLP result that we talked about, is that
you can't provide all three of
agreement, validity, and termination
in the crash fault model.
So, if you need to be tolerant of
processes crashing, then you can't do it
that way. Consensus protocols tend to be
designed in a very defensive way, so
that they'll be as robust as possible to
crashes. Um that's part of the reason
for all the complexity in Paxos.
So, although we can't get around this
impossibility result
in a situation where processes crash, we
can try our best to make things work out
most of the time.
Okay, so we can't just have one
acceptor, cuz it might crash.
Um in the examples that I've been using,
uh
we have three acceptors, typically. So,
if we have three acceptors,
how many of those can crash?
If I've got three,
and I still want my run of Paxos to
work,
will it still work
in a situation where an acceptor
crashes?
Could it still work?
Hmm, so somebody says no. So, if we have
three acceptors,
two is a majority of three, right?
So,
if you have three and everybody knows
that you have three and two is a
majority of three, but one has crashed,
then that's still a majority,
right?
So, if you have three,
you can tolerate having one acceptor
crashing and still have the algorithm
work.
It might not be great then, right? Then
you have no more room for acceptor
crashing. Um,
but at least you can tolerate one
acceptor crashing.
How about if I have five acceptors? How
many can crash?
Then two can crash, right?
So, in general,
you can handle a minority of the
acceptors crashing.
Uh, so,
if F
is the number of crashed acceptors that
you want to be tolerant of,
so if F is
the number
of acceptor failures,
you want to tolerate
you need
2F + 1 acceptors in all.
What about proposers? How many proposers
can crash?
Well, if all the proposers crash, that's
clearly not okay, right?
Can't really complete a run of Paxos if
we don't have any proposers.
Um
but it's it's fine to have just one,
right? So, all but one, right? Um so,
again, if if F is the number of failures
that I that I want to tolerate, um I
should have
F + 1 proposers.
So, if F is the number of proposer
failures that you want to tolerate, you
need F plus one.
So these numbers 2F plus one and F plus
one, you might hear thrown around a lot
when people are discussing Paxos. So
that's what they mean.
So that's how Paxos tolerates or that's
that's the degree to which it tolerates
crash faults. It's not bad. It's
reasonably tolerant of crash faults.
Okay. What about omission faults? How
does Paxos do under omission faults?
If I lose a message here and there
during a run of Paxos,
what could go wrong?
Well, maybe nothing, right? So for
instance,
if I send a prepare message to all
acceptors, I only need to hear back from
a majority of them. We talked about this
before. So things could still work fine
if the message gets lost on the way to
one out of three acceptors
if there are three, right?
Okay.
Well, what if what if I send a prepare
message and what if all of my messages
to acceptors got lost?
Say for a particular prepare message,
uh
someone yanked out the network cable and
so they all get lost. Then what do I do?
I'm the proposer. What do I do?
Now, I don't know that the messages got
lost, right? All I know is that I
haven't heard back from a majority of of
of acceptors with a promise.
So if I don't hear back after a while,
I'll time out, right? And I can just
send another one with a higher proposal
number.
So Paxos does okay under omission
faults, too. It might not terminate,
but then it might not terminate anyway,
right?
So,
Paxos actually does okay under omission
faults.
Uh now if all messages are lost, right,
then then nothing will happen.
Uh it might not terminate. Uh
but as we've seen, even in a case where
no messages are lost, uh
it might not terminate because we could
have the dueling proposers problem.
So,
its behavior under omission faults uh
could still be fine.
Questions about this?
Any questions about this?
Okay.
So, I want to spend a little bit of time
talking about other consensus protocols,
really very little time. Uh we aren't
going to discuss any of them in detail
um because my thinking is that uh now
that we've spent like a week talking
about Paxos,
um if you care about these other
protocols, you should be pretty well
equipped to go out and study them on
their own. Um but I want to at least
mention their names.
Um so, here's a few consensus protocols
that you might want to be aware of
um
other than Paxos.
So, one of them is called Viewstamped
Replication
or VSR.
Um
this was the work of
Brian Oki
and Barbara Liskov.
Uh in 1988.
Another one is Zab.
Um
which was done at Yahoo Research
in the late 2000s.
Um Zab stands for Zookeeper Atomic
Broadcast and it was part of a system is
part of a system called Zookeeper.
Uh which distributed systems uh which is
open source software distributed systems
often used for uh configuration
management.
Um so, configuration management uh
involves consensus. Um so, they have a
protocol uh called Zookeeper Atomic
Broadcast that's a consensus protocol uh
and they published a paper about it.
Um
and then a recent one
is Raft.
This was work done by
Diego Ongaro
uh and John Ousterhout at Stanford.
Uh in 2014.
Um so Raft's gotten a lot of press. Um I
I So, I graduated from grad school uh in
uh and Raft was all the rage uh during
that the end of my time in grad school.
Uh I gave a talk at Recon in 2013 and
Diego was there giving a talk and it was
extremely well-attended.
Um so, Raft uh is
the the the whole point of Raft is
understandability.
Uh and the the Raft paper uh is
extremely well-written, clearly written.
Uh so, I recommend Raft uh um not so
much because it's uh a novel consensus
protocol, because I would argue that
it's not, um but rather that it's
extremely well-explained consensus
protocol. Um So, interestingly, what all
of these have in common, VSR's, Zab, and
Raft, is that they're all for achieving
consensus on a sequence of values,
rather than just one.
Um so, they're more like Multi-Paxos.
Um they all also, as far as I understand
it, they all bake in leader election as
a fundamental part of the protocol. So,
recall that I mentioned one way to do a
consensus protocol would be to first
have leader election to decide on who
the proposer should be,
and then have that proposer do all the
proposing and then avoid the problem of
dueling proposers because you would only
have one. Uh this doesn't get around the
non-termination issue because the leader
election itself could fail to terminate.
Uh or if it didn't fail to terminate, uh
if you compromise on agreement rather
than on termination, then you could end
up with with two leaders and then you
would have dueling proposers anyway.
Um so, all of these protocols bake in
leader election as a fundamental part of
the protocol. Um
And this is part of the reason uh
perhaps like so for Raft for instance um
uh if you read the Raft paper um you'll
see that it does leader election. And
then from that point onward uh that uh
elected process is what gets to is the
only one that gets to propose values.
This is as opposed to what we looked at
with Paxos, it still works when you have
multiple proposers. So you aren't
required to do leader election.
Um
So um also I mentioned uh so they're all
for achieving consensus on a sequence of
values, which is perhaps one the most
common use case for using Paxos in the
real world. So they all optimize for
that common use case.
Uh so Raft in particular uh
is for this case of uh
when you when you want to
uh as as we as we talked about a second
ago um
uh when you want to have um
this sequence agree
um between every process. Uh and you
could you could think of each of these
as being a sort of log of the events
that have taken place, right? So um as
far as I know that's why it's called
Raft because it's for keeping the logs
together, if you will.
All right. So
There's a nice paper that compares and
contrasts different consensus protocols
um
which I recommend. Um
uh it's called
Vive la Différence.
Paxos versus Viewstamped Replication
versus Zab.
Uh
This is by
Van Renesse
Scheiper and Schneider
uh from 2014.
Uh there's a really nice picture in this
paper uh or really nice figure that
contrasts the uh the terminology that
all of these different protocols use.
They all have their own terminology uh
for the same things essentially. And
this paper has a sort of Rosetta Stone
that uh that puts all those pieces of
terminology next to each other and uh
and tells you what they mean.
So, as always, you're not expected to
read random papers that I mention in
class. Uh the only ones that I expect
you to read are the ones that I actually
assign as homework. Um but this might be
a good one to look at if you care about
knowing the differences between
consensus protocols.
All right. Um
that about wraps up what I have to say
about Paxos uh
and consensus protocols. Uh so,
let's do a quiz.
And then we'll in the last little bit of
time we have, we'll move on to talk
about something else.
Uh so there's a question about
Multi-Paxos in chat. Um
so here's our Multi-Paxos picture again.
Um
Uh so somebody somebody asked about
about this number right here. Um no this
is not the somebody asked if this was
the phase number. Um this isn't the
phase number. Uh this is this would be
like a sequence number. So for
Multi-Paxos since we're deciding on a
sequence of values, um you have to know
uh which value in the sequence you're
deciding on. Um so if it's like this
situation
uh
uh where you're you're trying to do
totally ordered broadcast and you're
trying to decide, okay, which event
should go in slot one and which event
should go in slot two and which event
should go in slot three, uh
then you need to know for a given
decision which slot am I deciding on
right now. Um and these could come out
of order, right? It's possible that you
achieve consensus on slot two before you
achieve consensus on slot one.
Uh so
um that's what this number is here. It's
a it's uh
um
which of the things that
in the sequence that you're supposed to
be deciding on are you currently
deciding on?
All right. We'll wait just a moment
longer.
Uh
for answers to the quiz to wrap up.
Okay.
Last thing I want to talk about
um
So,
this uh
The last thing I want to talk about
today is something called
active
and passive
replication.
So,
some people get confused and they'll say
things like
primary backup replication is active
replication. Um
and this isn't necessarily true.
Um
uh
So,
in fact, uh
uh we could
Let Let Let me define what they are
first and and and then we'll um
uh and and then we'll come back and talk
about uh
how the the the replication strategies
that we've talked about fit into these
categories. Um so, what is active
replication?
Active replication is wherein you
actually execute an operation on every
replica where you want it to take
effect.
Um so,
let's say that we're doing primary
backup
and we have a replicated bank account.
So, we have a client
and we have
our primary and our backups.
So, the client say deposits $50.
The primary broadcasts that out.
Uh whoops.
That should go there.
Um the backups respond to the primary
and the primary acknowledges the client.
So,
you could do this in a couple of ways.
You could have the operation that
deposits $50 actually get sent to all
the replicas and executed on them.
So, you could have this message that
gets sent sent out be
deposit $50.
Alternatively,
you could do this.
Let's say that the primary's original
balance was was $0. Or let's say that
everybody's original balance was $0.
Or to make it more interesting, let's
say the original balance is $20.
Then,
the primary could do this.
It could execute the deposit against
itself,
not commit it yet,
but then send out a message to everybody
else saying,
"The new balance of is $70."
Then, they would both acknowledge and
say, "Okay, the new balance is $70." So,
here only the primary actually executes
the deposit operation and then it sends
a state update to the backups. And that
would be called passive.
So, in passive replication, one replica
executes operations
and sends state updates to the others.
So, notice that either way it's primary
backup, right? It still uses this
pattern of client talks to the primary,
primary broadcasts the backups, backups
acknowledge the primary, and primary
acknowledges the client.
But passive and act But But But this
primary backup approach could be done in
either the passive way, or it could be
done in the active way.
Under what circumstances would you
choose to do one of these over the
other?
For example, when do you think that
active replication would be better?
Any thoughts on that?
Mhm.
The suggestion is that active
replication would be better for a write
operation. Well,
so for a read operation, nothing has to
go to the backups, right?
So, um any sort of operation where you
have these messages going sent over here
to the backups is going to be a write
operation.
Um but are there some kinds of write
operations where uh
where active replication would be
better?
Yeah, so I would argue if it's a case
where the updated state is large
and that message would take a lot of
bandwidth to send,
then that would be a case where passive
replication or or or might be might
where you where you might be at an at
advantage or excuse me, at a
disadvantage if you did passive
replication because if the updated state
is large, um like let's say the
operation is something like uh increment
everybody's like let's say let's say
instead of just one bank account, let's
say there are a million bank accounts.
And let's say the operation is increment
everybody's bank account by 1 cent.
Well, then you would have this gigantic
state change, right? And then you would
have to send that gigantic state change
to everybody uh using up a lot of
bandwidth.
Um whereas you could send this nice
compact message of update everybody's
bank account by 1 cent and that would
and then execute it individually on each
replica. So, that would be active. Um
so, if the updated state is large, uh
passive replication might not be such a
good way to go and active replication
might be the right way to go.
On the other hand, passive replication
might be better uh in cases where the
computation is really expensive to do.
So, you might want to avoid having to do
it all those times. So, somebody just
mentioned in chat, wouldn't it be better
to have one process do the work and uh
and have others receive the results of
doing that work instead of having to
repeat the work.
So, if the computation is expensive,
then it's then it's probably better to
go with passive replication. Or,
if it somehow depends on the local
process state, like if you want uh
the the computation to to to do
something that that depends on something
that that is unique to each of these,
right? Um
like if the if the computation needs to
uh
um
needs to use randomness somehow,
um then
if you call if if if you if
if if you if you try to randomly
generate a number on each process using
active replication, right? If you're
executing this operation, uh then then
that would be bad, right? Because you
would end up with a different result on
each one, and they're supposed to be
replicas, right?
So, somebody just asked in chat, "So,
active is better for a large amount of
data?" Well, it depends, right? So,
active is probably better if the result
of the of of updating the state would
would would require you to send this
really big state update out.
Um because then sending the state update
out would be really really expensive.
So, I don't know necessarily what you
mean by large amount of data.
So, active replication
is a synonym for what's known as state
machine replication.
The idea of state machine replication is
that you have a bunch of replicas that
all need to have the same operations
executed on them in the same order, and
therefore they go through the same
sequence of states.
You could accomplish this using primary
backup or chain replication with an
active replication approach. Or you
could run a consensus protocol that
decides on a sequence of values like
Multi-Paxos.
Every update that gets sent by the
client needs to get slotted into that
list of updates to do. So, you run your
consensus protocol once for every slot.
Or if you like, uh
you run the consensus protocol once for
each operation to decide which slot it
goes in. That's state machine
replication.
Um but active replication of any kind is
also state machine replication. They're
synonyms.
All right, that's it for today.
Um,
next time, uh, we're going to talk about
replica conflict resolution.
So, I'll see you next time.